the problem in Darfur is a is a version
of a problem we've seen many times in
the past Rwanda others where there's
there's a genocide or something that is
very close to a genocide taking place
within a country and so there's this
clash between the sovereignty of that
country the ability of it to control its
own affairs and the imperative of the
rest of the world to do something and of
course we have a Genocide Convention we
have a treaty on genocide the problem is
the Security Council is given the
ability to decide whether to sanction a
country whether to authorize an invasion
and so forth and and again each of the
permanent five members can veto and so
if there's a big status quo bias and so
one of things we see in Darfur are
countries like China being very
resistant in Kosovo in the Balkans in
the 1990s Russia played that role being
very resistant to any action that would
seem to to impinge upon the sovereignty
of the former Yugoslavia in the Kosovo
example the NATO countries the North
Atlantic Treaty Organization the Western
democracies went in anyway and acted
outside the scope of the UN system that
was very controversial but many people
felt that it was justified humanitarian
intervention we weren't seeking to take
over Yugoslavia we were seeking to stop
to avert a genocide and so that would
seem to apply equally well in in Darfur
of course the dark the the the view of
the the Sudanese is you know this is our
this is our issue and you can imagine if
you know during the era of slavery if
Britain and had said we're going to
invade the American South to free the
slaves you know they would have been
enormous resistance the idea well this
is our we're gonna work this problem out
ourselves so it's it's a it's an
understandable reaction that countries
want to protect their domain but of
course in the case of Darfur I think
one that's unjustified and so the real
question is how will the international
community find the willpower to act
which it is often in the past lacked
Rwanda being the best example 800,000
people killed when that could have been
averted relatively easily
if troops had been put in a Rox a
sovereign state so it's so essentially
the answer to the question of what if
there were a genocide is the same if
it's a rock or if it's any other any
other country in the world and of course
the reality is we're gonna have some
troop presence there and and right now
we have a vast troop presence so so so
from a legal point of view there's no
real difference genocide is illegal but
you run into this problem of you can't
just invade a country willy-nilly
so now morally I think there's a harder
question politically is a harder
question right what does the u.s. owe to
Iraq what do we what what's our what's
our role and what if that genocide
starts to occur would we then bring the
troops back and this is particularly
hard for the Democrats because
traditionally Democrats have been in
favor of humanitarian intervention where
as Republicans traditionally took the
view that that was the kind of thing
that our armed forces should not be used
for that's social work foreign policy is
social work
whereas we should we should reserve our
military power for real national
security threats so I think if Barack
Obama's president he'll have it'll be a
vexing issue about what to do if there's
something that starts to look like
ethnic cleansing going on but the legal
issues would be exactly the same